yeah this could work a lot of people how
they digest content on YouTube is
usually on their phones
70% of times while they're like taking a
[ __ ] this year Adrian has joined our
team it's very talented filmmaker back
here in college he was the guy who beat
us in every competition we entered he
happen to have the exact same taste and
filmmaking that we did but here we are
now we're working together which is more
or less the best most ideal way this
could all work out
I'm new here I'm the new kid at school
so I'm slowly getting acclimated to how
everyone works and what everyone's
positions are but I've DP'd two projects
that Nico and Sam has directed which are
lifeline and Rush now we've worked on
plenty of other projects together but we
haven't actually filmed a YouTube video
a corridor digital YouTube video process
is different because Adrian hasn't done
a lot of like YouTube stuff it's a
little bit more higher-end filmmaking
stuff he may not be able to shift gears
and shift into the more approachable
YouTube self filmmaking I have to make
seven videos this year but on top of
that I really want to implement like my
original ideas we're going to be shortly
here almost two months into the year if
agent has agreed to make seven original
videos how do we get those done at all
by the end of the year currently I think
I'm on my sixth iteration of ideas and
all of them are being shut down we're
going to be in a situation where we
haven't made anything we haven't made
any progress no he's got to come up with
something that we can make now he needs
to come up with something this week that
we can shoot in the next nine days I am
slowly learning that there is a corridor
way of getting these projects made that
consist of certain parameters these
parameters being shoot with what we have
under this roof and make sure that you
can shoot this in one or two days I'm
not used to them I'm used to shooting on
weekends I'm used to shooting for five
days straight the reason they're not
liking my ideas isn't per se that
they're bad ideas at least I don't think
so a lot of these ideas kind of revolved
around
outside parameters I gotta figure out a
different way of writing these things
2018 as referenced by Carmichael is not
the year of fashion it is though the
year of health it's evidenced by the
health desk craze standing desks that
these guys got I like to think of myself
as like a generally healthy guy I want
to try to see what works for me in order
to do that we need to do a little bit of
research and then come up with some of
our own options for the health desk for
this guy it's got more food you know you
can also drink it going on down there
you have membership how much is a
membership 50 bucks a month cheaper than
most gyms what do you like about this
I'd the ability to literally just move
out all the other stand like this just
spread the weight this is too too short
for you I would feel this should need to
raise to the monitors up high you are
arching your your your sit forward
trying to stand up right here a little
bit pull that difficult like you're
pulling your belly button straight back
why would I do that that straightens
your lower back and then lift your chest
at the same time and boom straight back
and then drink some of this and then
drink some of this I'm just gonna stand
one step at a time
this one is pretty it's like pretty
sturdy
I do like like the hand height is
comfortable but I don't wanna I don't
want to look down I want to look
straight ahead that's definitely better
options
I would like my hands to be in front of
me no like if I did oh god help desk
these active desk chairs want you to
transform the way you sit in case you
haven't heard sitting is the new smoking
Wooper chair okay it's got a spring $960
what do you say posture is important
yeah you need to sit not like this chair
sucks so you're sitting up keep that
spine aligned a little better keeps your
organs in good place you can drink your
coffee and it makes its way all the way
down but getting stuck anywhere anyway
I'm not really interested in a chair
though because I'm more interested in
what else can I do with my body
well dance working whoo I read me little
desk so you're always walking exercise
device the mobile workers workforce
affordable works it's like Sam's chair
with the desk built-in mm-hmm here's
here's my question if you sit at a
mobile desk what exactly do you do if
you just listen to headphones and look
at a tablet all day you're an artist
crazy clever these these eyes oh here we
go geek uber geeky futuristic
workstation that lets you work in any
position even zero gravity position zero
gravity that's how the most
sophisticated all-in-one workstations
look a chair with hydraulic lifting
action oh my god oh my god is video
anyone who has an old work desk out
there I want to try it can we can you
hit this up so we can try it here's what
we've learned so far there's a lot of
options yeah and I don't know if any of
them are gonna work and here's the thing
the cheapest that any of them are is
like a hundred bucks I don't think I'm
really willing to risk a hundred bucks
just yet to like invest in a health desk
system I think there's enough things
around the office where we could
probably just come up with a few
alternatives on our own
[Music]
[Music]
this could work
you ready daddy ready dude you know on
second thought I think I'm just gonna
get a standing desk I switched to an
ergonomic chair it's pretty great I
highly recommend it he kind of needs
strong knees to do it I haven't seen any
issues so far but while most people like
to be more active when they have a
health desk Nico's going the alternate
direction makes a Squarespace for
sponsoring this video
whether you for sponsoring this video
where they need can I not speak today
thanks to Squarespace for sponsoring
this video
whether you need a domain website or
online store make your next move with
Squarespace today we need to add a video
page to the corridor website want to
take our latest video from YouTube and I
want to put it as a page on the website
we have everything else set up it's
going to be super ridiculously easy I'm
going to show you just how fast we can
get this done go we go to main
navigation we click add a page boom
right taking the sunglasses off pages
empty new page title latest video the
URL already from over here let me pull
it quick boom there it is add it here
boom let's get rid of this text right
here come on baby boom right there
adding banner and boom we're done how
long was that on the website right now
yeah this is live on the website right
now Squarespace has beautiful
award-winning templates that are great
for any kind of website so whether
you're a designer a restaurant a
musician consider them for what you want
to do it's really easy if award-winning
customer service they have an all-in-one
platform so there's nothing to install
patch or upgrade ever start your free
trial today by going to Squarespace calm
slash Sam and Nico and you get 10% off
your first purchase happy hunting
[Music]
the idea is for today to be shooting you
know videos and also helping out other
bigger projects - we were hopefully
going to be shooting one of his ideas by
now you know I've come up with an idea
that I think works within the given
parameters I actually scripted out the
entire eleven pages the concerns that I
have right now it's a little bit
abstract it's really out there there are
a lot of questions and as this short
progresses I wouldn't say they
necessarily answer them outright but it
leaves the viewer needing to come up
with their own answers which sounds like
a cop-out like hey I couldn't figure out
an ending and you guys just need to
figure it out but [ __ ] that it's
abstract and it's awesome you need to
scale your production accordingly
because people don't really care if you
spend money on YouTube videos they just
want funny ideas or cool things to see
you know it's that's all that really
matters it's the it's the essence of
filmmaking I'm gonna try to go for very
intense psychological [ __ ] storm can
shoot this in a day or two and we're
using everything that we have under the
roof of the studio if I'm worried about
whether or not his style will work with
YouTube and the budgets that we have the
only way to really solve that is to
shoot things they just need to work
within the parameters that you give them
that's just my take I still gotta talk
to Jake Jake's reading the script right
now it would be nice if it's met with as
much enthusiasm and excitement as I hope
but if not well it's likely it's been
what six seven drafts of ideas that I
think were suitable in my mind but
obviously I'm realizing like I got a
scale back with what I thought was
achievable so we'll see what he says
he has announced that he got the pen
paper outlook I like that you're hitting
the scale this that was that was your
greatest problem with the last view
scripty I think I think I'm learning man
yeah I think I'm learning how these guys
operate it's too off and here's why
here's why because you could accomplish
exactly what you're trying to accomplish
in half the time I do like the slow burn
feel I I don't like the idea of turning
it into a quick cut you to be like just
to the horn good cut I don't want it to
be quick cut it seems like you're slow
burning the viewer for the sake of slow
burning the viewer because it has a
viewer your natural instinct is to go oh
this is interesting this is visual
there's a character and a strange
situation where is this all going
I think you still need to give them a
little bit more you have to balance that
with what people's attention span is on
the platforms usually when I watch
content full screen volume up
concentrating on the piece I have to I
have a hard time like realizing that a
lot of people how they digest content on
YouTube is usually on their phones
70% of times while they're like taking a
[ __ ] a lot of the times they're just
like this didn't get to the point quick
enough swipe that's a shame I'm gonna
take all that okay reread the script
with that we all had information in the
back of my head see if I can condense it
right I like where you're coming from
I really like the idea of trying to make
him feel more unsafe because at the end
of the day that's what I'm trying to get
across I'm so if we're adding an extra
element where he feels unsafe and then
yeah sure I think that's awesome dude I
got to go break this thing down today
and we're shooting in nine days Adrian
just notify this by the passion on his
sleeve he's like dude this is my vision
just as it is important to understand
how your viewer will be watching a movie
same thing applies when you're doing
YouTube videos you need to write it with
an understanding of how it will be
consumed you can't just write something
in a vacuum for creativity's sake you
can but you can't expect people to watch
it and you can see this in modern movies
so round off the edges on things to make
it approachable to a wider audience now
I'm not saying
he needs to make the story different all
I'm saying is make it approachable from
somebody that doesn't know what the
source material is so that when you have
somebody who's consuming it from a phone
they'll watch it and enjoy it otherwise
you're gonna get a niche audience who's
super hardcore about the source material
they're gonna be the only ones who watch
it and then when you go man I worked so
hard on this I put so much soul into
this why didn't anyone else care about
this because it was too deep down a
rabbit hole of it has to be like this so
it's something that we're faced with
every day and I'm hyper aware of it now
that's where art comes in you have to
draw the line between what's relatable
and what's original you know and that
really more so than originality it's
really the art of repetition this video
anime self-driving cars it's very
challenging video because it's big we've
been working on it for a few weeks
already now it's finally time to shoot
and there's a lot building up to this
video I don't want to fail anyone is
this anime thing gonna work be too
ridiculous like when you want to go
over-the-top and goofy when do you want
to play serious these are still the
nuances that I have yet to figure out so
that makes me a little nervous